[Música]
hoy les quiero presentar a una amiga que
conocí en un viaje
su nombre es clarita ellas de bariloche
y como ese conocía cientos miles de
niños que cambiaron su vida mediante una
prótesis impresa en 3-d es ahora como es
que conozco a clarita estando ella en
bariloche y yo en buenos aires hoy les
voy a contar esa historia también mi
historia la historia de una abogada que
estaba todos los días
sentada enfrente una computadora siendo
viendo a tribunales trabajando en un
estudio jurídico y un día decide dejar
todo eso de lado subirse a un
laboratorio todoterreno y entregar
prótesis impresas en 3-d
mi nombre es alicia o suv y hacía varios
años tenía un objetivo por sonar ya
hacer algo solidario el problema es que
lo venía postergando porque no sabía ni
cómo ni cuándo y dónde lo podía hacer
pero avanzando en mi carrera
universitaria llegué a lo que todo el
mundo podría considerar el sueño de un
abogado
participar en la organización de los
estados americanos es la oea así un
presente un proyecto que ayudaba a miles
de niños en zonas rurales
el problema principal que organiza todos
los estados miembros en la región del
hemisferio para poder aplicarlo
entonces empecé a buscar otras
alternativas en latinoamérica y es donde
descubrimos atomic la ftc
quizás algunos escucharon hablaré de
esta organización otros no tanto pero
tome clases lo que busca es mediante sus
desarrollos tecnológicos mejorar la
calidad de vida de las personas y
haciéndolo de la manera más sencilla
posible sin importar su edad sin
importar su ubicación geográfica sin
importar su estatus económico
durante todos estos años atomic fue
desarrollando diferentes proyectos pero
hay uno que es el más conocido por todos
y el más emocional también la entrega de
prótesis 100% gratuitas para la persona
que lo solicita
el inconveniente es que investigando un
poco más me cuenta que tome que era más
que eso que la entrega de prótesis
gratuitas trataban de convertir una
situación de bullying que se estaba
dando con los niños en la escuela que no
tenía ni malo ni brazo y convertirlos en
superhéroes y cómo hacían esto no
solamente generar un cambio físico sino
también psicológico y neurológico
entregando prótesis con por ejemplo los
colores desde el equipo de fútbol
favorito con los colores del superhéroe
favorito prótesis que brillaban en la
oscuridad algunas que tenían luces otras
que cambiaban de color con la luz del
día imagínense esto y encima lo hacían
de la manera más fácil posible
simplemente lo único que tenían que
hacer era sacar una foto de su muñón
sobre una hoja cuadriculada subir todos
estos datos a la página que nosotros
tenemos y ahí directamente un algoritmo
se encarga
de generar el archivo con el diseño de
la prótesis pero no quedaba ahí sino que
este archivo viajaba como si fuese un
mail a la cuenta de un embajador
bueno mejor es una persona que tiene una
impresora 3d que además este algoritmo
se encarga de que usted es la forma más
cercana en el lugar más cercano a la
persona que la solicita
este embajador puede ser una persona
física una organización una escuela
quiero que imaginen lo que esto
significaba para una abogada
a veces llegaba a tribunales y tenía que
llenar un formulario me decían bueno
pase por acá doctora y me sentaba en
frente de una máquina de escribir o una
máquina de escribir del siglo pasado
estamos en el año 2019 o por ejemplo
llegaba presentado buen escrito y me
decían bueno hay un adjuntamos al
expediente y lo cosen de hecho lo siguen
conociendo con hilo y aguja
y acá está enfrente es un proyecto
totalmente diferente un proyecto
colaborativo un proyecto que utiliza las
nuevas tecnologías como puede ser la
impresión 3 red entonces me dije bueno y
empezaría
si salgo a mi zona de confort me adapto
a esta nueva tecnología y decidió ser
voluntaria
hace algunos días se cumplieron dos años
de estar ayudando en esta organización
regulando el trabajo de 1400 embajadores
en más de 44 países organizando
manotones que son maratones de entregas
de manos o regulando o estableciendo las
pautas específicamente del envío de
prótesis alrededor del mundo
hasta ahora creo que todos coinciden que
es un proyecto increíble pero teníamos
un problema la demanda iba creciendo
cada vez más en algunos pueblos o en
algunas localidades no teníamos
embajadores ni tampoco existía el correo
nos llegaba el correo allí entonces
sobre una reunión del año pasado dijimos
qué tal si cambiamos qué pasaría si
fuéramos a la casa de esas personas no
queríamos la puerta le entregaríamos la
prótesis y diremos la cara de felicidad
de ellos sabiendo que habíamos viajado
tanto
pero qué pasaría si además en vez de
crear esa prótesis en nuestro taller
citó el aseo autónoma de buenos aires
las crías éramos en el camino pueblo a
pueblo ciudad a ciudad lo llamamos
argentina ton y de paso aprovecha de
álamos y fuéramos a las diferentes
escuelas sean técnicas o no y digamos
una charla sobre estas nuevas
tecnologías sin centígrados
incentivaremos a más jóvenes
a innovar
ahora toda esta idea increíble que les
estoy contando tenía un gran problema
era el financiamiento imagínense peaje
en hasta alojamiento entonces como esta
es una organización que innova y vuelve
a innovar decidimos hacer lo siguiente
un tuit
esta cosa enorme era la que nos lo que
nos imaginábamos
yo no le puedo explicar se viralizó a la
cantidad organizaciones que nos llamaban
nos decían qué es lo que están haciendo
porque nos están robando de todas partes
nos están twitteando no entendemos
absolutamente nada
por suerte hubo una organización que no
solamente decidió apoyarnos en este
proyecto sino en todas las ideas que
tuviéramos a futuro
hoy los voy a llevar de viaje conmigo 25
mil 400 kilómetros 120 días 80 ciudades
23 provincias 4 pasos fronterizos el
equipo chino tubaro fundador de atomic
lab aldeano pelusso y yo
con una camioneta quiero que imagines de
una camioneta con una impresora 3d
suspendida en el aire para que pudiera
imprimir en el camino alimentada por
tres paneles solares todo hecho con
nuestras propias manos entregamos más de
102 prótesis y se sumaron como
embajadores más de 172 nuevas personas
ahora
todo este viaje no lo hicimos sólo
sabíamos que no le íbamos a hacer solos
creo que imaginen o que piense lo que es
dejar absolutamente todo el lado de la
familia el trabajo los amigos subirse
una camioneta y salir a la ruta pero por
suerte tuvimos la ayuda de todas estas
personas como les decía las señoras de
la mercería de rosario del kiosco de
córdoba que nos dieron el velcro para
poner en las prótesis los que nos
esperaban con algo caliente porque
fuimos en pleno invierno ushuaia ahí
pueden ver las familias que nos
esperaban con asados de hecho pensamos
que habíamos llegado el día de
cumpleaños de alguien y no los esperaban
con asados con todas las familias
reunidas se habían cortado pueblos
completos no lo podíamos creer la
persona que entregó la hoja cuadriculada
para sacar la foto el que los viole lo
que nos vio en el noticiero y llamaron
quienes por ejemplo en toda la casa de
camping que tenemos ahí una foto más
adelante desde la casa de camping que
agarraron y nos vendieron a un precio
absolutamente irrisorio una bolsas de
dormir para que hagamos si esta noche
nos quedáramos en impenetrable y
pudiéramos todos juntos ensamblar una
prótesis para buena ética de la
comunidad
entonces la radio de local y que nos
ayudaron muchísimo que iban corriendo la
noticia pueblo pueblo para que nosotros
llegáramos rápido para poder hacer las
prótesis
pero también conocimos historias de vida
increíbles como la de abril de san
francisco córdoba que después entre los
humanos son más manos pies por favor que
le acompañen hasta el colegio allí
habría el fue a su jardín citó allí
abril fue con mostrando su mano a todos
los compañeros todo estaban
absolutamente sorprendidos ahora tenemos
un grave problema abril estaba feliz
pero teníamos a medio curso de nenes
llorando porque también querían una
prótesis
fíjense con esa frescura con esa
inocencia de los nenes ellos también
querían una prótesis
o por ejemplo acá tenemos la historia de
lucio de vietnam y cuando llegamos a
entregar su mano nos damos cuenta que
tiene un hermanito y siempre el problema
con los hermanitos hasta yo no sé si era
porque se puso celoso porque quería
imitarlo o porque lo admiraba pero que
hizo fue el hermanito de lució sacarse
su media y se la puso en la mano una
mamá decía nunca y eso esto y así
estuvieron todos jugando toda la tarde
andando en bicicleta tirándose en
tobogán estaba jugando como si fueran
excavadoras creo que de hecho todavía
esa media sigue lavándose pero lo que es
más importante acá es que entienden el
concepto de la felicidad compartida
entre ellos
tenemos la historia también de dafne de
ushuaia que ya nos contaba entre mate y
mate que siempre de chicas con días
humanos
escondía su lo que ella consideraba un
problema pero un día decidió cambiar de
perspectiva arroz lleno a los datos y
pidió la prótesis más colorida que pueda
existir
lo que ella antes consideraba un
problema ahora le está empoderando y no
era en la mano les aseguro que no era la
mano era su cambio de perspectiva
y por último como la historia de raúl
desde allí que el puntualmente trabajado
con su hijo en el campo y tenían como
política no trabajar de noche porque
obviamente por los peligros que
involucraba eso lamentablemente pierde
su mano pero él y fíjense la historia de
resiliencia de raúl esta palabra que se
suele usar esto está muy de moda ahora
resiliencia es inmediatamente acepta su
realidad tranquiliza a su hijo y ahora
lo que hace es trabajar con algo tan
detallista y puntilloso como ser
relojero
he visto como personas por primera vez
aprendían a escribir aprendían a jugar o
andaban en bicicleta pintaban tocaban la
guitarra y algunos que lo volvían a
hacer después de su accidente
les podría así contar cien historias más
cada momento que vivimos es único e
irrepetible lo que sí les por contar es
lo que a mí me pasó todo este proceso me
transformó y me fortaleció esta decisión
de un día de hacer algo diferente y de
incluir algún parámetro positivo en mi
vida me hizo sentir más fuerte de lo que
creía inclusive para acompañar a cada
una de las 102 historias que conocimos
ahora yo creo que todos aunque sea a
nivel íntimo pensamos que tenemos
ciertas fortalezas ciertas virtudes
ciertos talentos yo les pido que se
atrevan a hacer las cosas de manera
diferente sean el cambio para ustedes y
para otros involucren se coloque el
espacio involucren se con la ciudad en
la que quieren vivir justamente cosas
solidarias o no no interesa
se acuerdan de esa historia de la foto
de clarita y todo lo que les conté de
este objetivo solidario que no sabía por
qué había surgido bueno lo entendí desde
la primera hasta la última mano que
entregamos en navidad de navidad pasada
se puede ver en todas estas fotos pero
me gusta resumirlo en una frase lo que
más me gusta de la ayuda recíproca es
interesada entre dos personas en no
saber al final quién tuvo la suerte de
conocer a la otra muchas gracias
[Aplausos]